Salut les naturalistes !
Si quelques passionnés comme moi peuvent
se régaler en observant ce "Gastéruption à
javelot", il faut bien avouer qu'un tel
insecte a plutôt tendance à faire peur.
Mais pas de panique, ce n'est
pas un dard que vous voyez.
C'est un ovipositeur, autrement dit
un organe destiné à pondre des œufs.
La grande famille des guêpes auquel il
appartient souffre malheureusement trop souvent
d'un délit de faciès et comme c'est aussi le
cas pour les araignées je vous propose pour ce
nouvel épisode un autre regard sur ces mal aimés.
Générique !
Trop souvent nous avons sous-estimé
le rôle des guêpes et des araignées.
Et que ce soit dans la pollinisation des plantes
ou dans la régulation des populations d'autres
insectes, leur rôle dans l'équilibre
de nos écosystèmes sont fondamentaux.
Commençons avec du lourd : les araignées !
Du lourd, du lourd ! Façon de parler
puisque sur les 1750
espèces d'araignées identifiés en France,
la moitié ne mesure environ que 5 mm.
Il faudra vous rendre à l'évidence,
dans un jardin qui laisse un minimum de place
à la nature, les araignées sont partout.
Et tant mieux car ce sont de redoutables
prédateurs qui ingurgitent 10 à 20% de leur
propre poids par jour et qui agissent
donc comme un insecticide 100% bio.
Un vieil adage raconte d'ailleurs qu'une maison
abritant des araignées est une maison saine.
Que ce soit pour tisser une toile,
enrober une proie ou tricoter un coco
toutes les araignées produisent de la soie.
Pour chasser, comme beaucoup d'araignées,
l'épeire fascier ou "Argiope frelon" utilise
la soie pour bâtir une toile géométrique.
Celle-ci présente en son centre un motif blanc en
zigzag appelé "Stabilimentum"
dont le rôle reste encore flou.
Certains spécialistes pensent qu'il aide à attirer
les proies alors que d'autres affirment qu'ils
facilitent le camouflage de l'araignée.
La soie peut aussi intervenir dans
la reproduction des araignées.
La "Pisaure admirable" l'utilise ici
pour fabriquer une pouponnière en forme de cloche
où les jeunes vont demeurer sous sa surveillance
jusqu'à être capable de chasser par eux-même.
Si c'est pas mignon, ça !
La "Pisaure" fait partie des très nombreux
arachnides qui ne tissent pas de toile
pour piéger leurs victimes, mais qui
privilégient un mode de vie errant.
Ces araignées chassent alors leurs
proies en leur courant derrière,
en leur bondissant dessus ou en
se dissimulant dans la végétation.
Cette araignée crabe, également appelée "thomise
variable", est une spécialiste de la chasse à
l'affût, cette fois cachée dans les fleurs de
la phacélie. Elle peut patienter des heures pour
capturer l'insecte convoité.
Non, pas celui là...
Raté !
Bien trop gros...
Voilà !
Ce papillon sera parfait !
Revenons maintenant aux guêpes, dont
la diversité des espèces et des modes
de vie est tout aussi grande que celle des
araignées. Y compris dans un jardin vivant.
Les souvenirs que nous laissent ces insectes
sont trop souvent limités aux très rares
piqûres que les guêpes nous infligent. Il
serait pourtant dommage d'oublier toutes
les autres observations ou nos guêpes sociales
profitent sagement de nos jardins durant l'été,
comme ce "Poliste gaulois" venu se délecter
de nectar sur les fleurs du fenouil.
Attention toutefois, aux apparences,
car le costume jaune et noir n'est
pas exclusif aux guêpes sociales
et les usurpateurs sont nombreux.
Cet insecte, par exemple, avec de
petites antennes et une seule paire
d'ailes membraneuses, est en réalité
un "Syrphe" apparenté aux mouches. Il
ne possède pas de dard pour chasser ou
se défendre et ne peut donc pas piquer.
Il existe une très grande diversité de guêpes.
La plupart ne sont pas rayées en jaune et noir,
ne vivent pas en colonies et
sont incapables de piquer.
C'est le cas de cette minuscule
"Chryside dorée" ou guêpe-coucou,
une espèce solitaire et parasitoïde puisqu'elle
pond dans les nids d'autres insectes.
En avril 2021, j'ai mis en place dans le
jardin différents aménagements à base de
sable pour tenter d'attirer
des insectes fouisseurs.
La première surprise a eu lieu seulement
trois mois plus tard avec l'arrivée d'une
nouvelle espèce de guêpe, "l'Ammophile
des sables". Cette femelle a trouvée ici
le sol idéal pour creuser une dizaine de
terriers de 5 centimètres de profondeur.
Dans chaque tunnel, elle pondra un œuf
et déposera une chenille qui servira de
nourriture pour sa larve. Le terrier sera
ensuite bouché et la larve trouvera dans
ce logis souterrain une protection contre
l'hiver avant d'émerger au printemps suivant.
J'espère que cette série de six épisodes vous
a donné envie d'accueillir la biodiversité
dans votre jardin, car c'est indéniablement
chez soi que commence la protection du monde
vivant. Et si vous avez envie de poursuivre
cette aventure de proximité, je vous invite
une nouvelle fois à découvrir mon
film "Jardin sauvage" ou le livre
"Safari au jardin". Alors, merci pour votre
soutien et j'espère à bientôt. Tchao !